parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro l'hiver
approche et la question de la perte de
chaleur dans nos habitations se pose un
forum eco habitat s'est tenue à jouy en
josas pour obtenir quelques conseils la
faune sauvage est parfois bien caché
dans la forêt de chant garnier pour la
découvrir une balade été proposé au
début du mois par l'association ville
verte nous y avons participé
mais tout d'abord un nouvel
établissement scolaire a ouvert ses
portes ici à guyancourt les écoliers de
jean lurçat et elsa triolet sont
dorénavant dans une école à haute
qualité environnementale
visite guidée avec catherine de l'atome
et william l
une façade tout en bois de grandes
fenêtres dans les classes et un toit
végétalisé pour réguler la chaleur voilà
à quoi ressemble la toute nouvelle école
d'ursa triolet à guyancourt ouverte
depuis ce lundi matin l'établissement
scolaire reçoit dix classes de primaire
et six classes de maternelle il est
classé hpe haute qualité environnement
se
d'abord un projet technique avec des
matériaux nobles de qualité 70% des cols
est en bois une gestion également
centraliser des équipements avec la
régulation du chauffage la régulation de
la qualité de l'air de l'humidité est
également un projet managériale c'est à
dire que ça a pu mettre l'ensemble des
services de la ville autour de la
qualité environnementale il est dans une
démarche projet un accent particulier a
été porté sur la lumière par exemple des
puits naturels ont été réalisés le
facteur lumière jour comme on dit est
d'importance et notamment la haute
qualité environnementale nous oblige à
être vigilant là dessus ensuite toutes
les lumières naturelles sont amenés avec
des sources d'énergie les moins
consommatrices possible des régulations
que l'on il obtient à l'aide de la gtb
ans la gestion technique du bâtiment ou
gestion technique centralisée
tout ça s'est régulé par des automates
donc on essaye de perdre le moins
possible d'énergie et d'avoir un niveau
d'éclairement les plus hautes cimes
impossible objectif une réduction de 30%
de la consommation
coût de cette nouvelle école dont le
chantier avait démarré il ya 14 mois 13
millions d'euros dont 1,5 million
d'euros de subvention versée par le
conseil général et le conseil régional
l'école hq à et 15 à 20% plus cher qu'un
établissement classique un surcoût
amortissable en 10 à 15 ans quant à
l'ancienne école elle sera déconstruite
à la place 150 logements mixtes les
travaux vont démarrer début janvier 2015
les éco-gestes ce sont ces petites
habitudes à adopter pour faire des
économies d'énergie des gestes un peu
anodin mais qui peuvent faire beaucoup
pour nous les faire découvrir l' agence
locale de l'énergie et du climat de
saint-quentin lance un défi nous sommes
avec laurence moudon la responsable du
défi familles à énergie positive bonjour
laurence alors est-ce que vous
m'expliquer quel est le but de ce défi
alors c'est réduire sa consommation
d'énergie de 8% à la maison en faisant
des gestes simples et surtout sans
investissement et sans perte de confort
qui peut participer à ce type de défi
alors un foyer tous les foyers du sud
yvelines peuvent participer à leur foyer
ça peut être personne célibataire pacsé
avec ou sans enfants là tout foyer
constitué vous parlez de foyers on parle
de maisons d'appartements les deux se
soit mué en appartement ou en maison
individuelle
l'important c'est d'avoir la possibilité
de voir ces compteurs pour pouvoir faire
les relevés au niveau des dates ce que
vous nous dire le déroulement oui alors
premiers relevés 1er décembre et dernier
relevé le 30 avril avec des relevés
intermédiaire bien sûr mais c'est les
deux les deux relevés qui vont jalonner
le défi au niveau des inscriptions ça se
passe comment alors sur le site internet
familles à énergie positive et il ya une
grande carte de france avec tous les
toutes les régions qui participe au défi
qui sont représentés et on va avoir
l'île de france qui représentait avec le
cdp est ce qu'on peut parler des preuves
pour ce défi alors c'est pas des
épreuves c'est pouvoir tester des éco
gestes qui sont connues de certains pas
connus qui sont ignorés d'autres qui
vont que l'on croit anodin mais qui font
beaucoup d'économies d'énergie c'est
pour aller tester à la maison et mesurer
un petit peu leur impact grâce aux
relevés et donc justement part de ces
éco gestes est ce que vous pouvez me
donner des exemples de ces gestes à
adopter ab c'est très simple s'est
éteint la lumière quand on quitte une
pièce
prendre une douche de cinq minutes si
possible et
changé peut-être ces lampes si on a des
lampes qui consomment beaucoup
mettre un couvercle sur la casserole
pour que pour dépenser moins d'énergie
pour chauffer la le repas
voilà plein de gestes qui sont qui sont
assez simples et qui sont toutes
répertoriées dans un petit livret qui en
fait le guide des 100 éco gestes que
chaque famille aura chaque foyer aura
pour tout au long du défi pour consulter
tout au long du défi justement nous
sommes ici dans une cuisine est ce que
pour vous montrer quelques éco-gestes by
bien sûr alors par exemple pour le
réchauffer à un repas il est plus
intéressant d'utiliser micro-ondes que
d'allumer un four que d' allumer le four
classique traditionnelle qui va
consommer plus d'énergie le fonds micro
ou le foie mais fondre à consommer moins
d'énergie moins de pendant moins
longtemps autre petite astuce c'est par
exemple les multiprises interrupteur
lorsqu'on a plus besoin de l'équipement
donc par exemple le micro et reste avec
une petite veille si on est un plat
multiprise eh bien il n'y a plus la
petite veille donc c'est des petits
gestes d'économie d'énergie qui vont
permettre et bien en cumul de réduire sa
facture d'énergie autre petite astuce il
il existe des petits appareils qui
s'appelle des mousseurs et qui vont
permettre de réduire la pression de
l'eau le débit de l'eau donc c'est juste
des petits les équipements installés sur
et sur les robinets afin de la sensation
du débit d'eau reste la même par contre
si on mesure il ya moins d'eau qui
s'écoule autres petites astuces et de
laisser toujours le mitigeur sur la
position froid comme ça s'est vite
utilise de tirer de l'eau chaude alors
qu'on n'a pas forcément besoin de vos
sont par exemple pour se laver les mains
on peut se laver les mains à l'eau
froide alors l'objectif c'est 8 %
d'économie d'énergie dans le cas du défi
l'année dernière par exemple les
familles les cinq familles qui ont
participé sur sud yvelines elles ont
fait 15% en moyenne d'économie d'énergie
donc finalement c'est déjà ce qu'ils
peuvent aller
assez loin on est par exemple diminué
d'un pour cent par an diminué d'un degré
sont juste à consignes de chauffage à la
maison c'est à peu près 7 % d'économie
de chauffage effectué par degré donc il
ya eu 5 55 familles dans le sud yvelines
qui se sont présentés mais en france
étaient 7700 familles qui ont participé
au défi est donc en moyenne sur toute la
france s'étaient 18% économies d'énergie
nous on est deux fronts sud yvelines on
a fait 15% et on a aussi des
participants qui veulent refaire encore
cette année le défi en espérant pouvoir
continuer à faire des économies
mondiales qu'ils avaient déjà fait des
économies avec derrière elle pense
qu'elle peut encore en faire donc c'est
vraiment ça va merci beaucoup jour ans
mini pour cet entretien vous offrir on
vient de voir il y a les petits gestes
du quotidien mais il ya aussi les grands
gestes à faire dans une maison pour
réaliser des économies plusieurs
solutions existent direction le forum
eco habitat 2 juillet aux usa avec des
images de william l
laine de verre polyester liège des
produits naturels comme synthétique au
choix du client mais avant tout il faut
prêter attention à l'état actuel de la
maison il faut tout d'abord commencé par
regarder quel est l'état de la maison
s'il ya des travaux importants à prévoir
dans la maison ou si c'est simplement
une redécoration de la maison que les
clients souhaitent faire si ce sont des
travaux importants il faut peut-être
faire appel un thermicien pour évaluer
effectivement le niveau de déperdition
de la maison et pouvoir je dirais
reprendre les éléments les plus
importants les plus dé perdre itif de la
construction actuelle faire des devis
auprès de techniciens pour rétablir les
capacités thermiques d'une maison et
déterminer les principales sources de
perte de chaleur les fenêtres sont
souvent les zones où la chaleur
s'échappe le plus fréquemment notamment
le simple vitrage mais il n'y a pas
seulement les fenêtres la chaudière ou
la toiture peuvent être des pertes de
chaleur et d'énergie les isolants
naturels sont plus onéreux car peu
développée donc les travaux ont un coût
mais l'état et les collectivités ont mis
en place plusieurs aides financières qui
peuvent bénéficier à la fois du crédit
d'impôt pour la condition énergétique
donc qui résulte de la nouvelle loi pour
la transition énergétique depuis le 1er
septembre 2014 une peuvent bénéficier en
fonction des revenus de la frime
rénovation énergétique de 1350 euros du
programme habiter mieux qui est porté
par l'anah agence nationale pour
l'amélioration de l'habitat et puis
aussi l'éco prêt qui est un prêt à taux
zéro des aides qui existent depuis au
moins janvier 2014 le crédit d'impôt
passé de taux de 15 à 20% à un taux
unique à 30% quelles que soient les
travaux fenêtres chaudières ou isolation
le prêt à taux zéro permet de bénéficier
d'un montant maximal de 30 mille euros
et sans condition de ressources
partir à la découverte de la faune
sauvage de la forêt de chant garnier et
apprendre à reconnaître les traces des
animaux c'était le but d'une balade
proposée par l'association ville verte
un reportage de catherine zola tôt
yolaine thorez elodie moines on pourrait
travailler sangliers qu'est ce qui
pourrait nous laisser comme traces
ou indices de présence
comment
fabien leurs excréments très bien les
instruments planches photographiques
avec empreintes d'ongulés règle est à la
main pour mesurer les traces et c'est
parti pour deux heures et demie de
balade dans la forêt de chant garnier à
magny les hameaux une forêt qui
appartient à lagence des espaces verts
d'île de france le but montrer toutes
les diversités que l'on peut trouver
dans un espace boisé les grands animaux
comme tout ce qui est servi d vont
déposer des traces sur le sol avec leurs
pas et on peut mesurer avec des
réglettes sont donc des réglettes 1 cm
la taille de la trace et ensuite essayer
de trouver est-ce que ça appartient en
serre est ce que ça appartient à un
sanglier est ce que cela passera peut
être un chevreuil et ainsi de suite donc
on va mesurer les empreintes en fonction
aussi des planches qu'on a puisque
toutes les empreintes sont pas les mêmes
de la diversité parfois bien cachés
commencer par les oiseaux comme le geai
des chênes les pics épeiches qu'on
entend régulièrement rouge-gorge qu'on
entend beaucoup les mésanges
charbonnières mésange bleue les piverts
les pics épeiches pas forcément visibles
à l'oeil nu par contre ces oiseaux
laisse des traces dans les kindle
une noisette coincé dans les cordes d'un
chêne celle en nourriture c'est quoi
cette cette bille de cette petite bille
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à votre avis
qui a happé par ça un peu plus loin une
excroissance sur une feuille de chêne
dans laquelle s'installe une larve
d'insecte qui se nourrit de celle de la
petite boule là
c'était très sympa la petite boule qui
pousse sur la feuille de chêne et qui
fait le nid de l'animal ses traits de
l'insecte plutôt des petits insectes qui
se met dans l'est dans les glandes comme
ça ça aurait qu elle n'y pense pas quand
on se balade à l'étude il ya plein il ya
plein de vie en fait de partout encore
un peu plus loin des emprunts dans la
boue là aussi une fois voir le regard
aiguisé chevreuil ou sanglier difficile
à déterminer à qui on a deux ans greny
von arx pattes le sanglier à 4 en place
qui les posent on voit la forêt un peu
autrement on apprend on apprend des
choses les enfants participent non c'est
bien conscient d'un temps merveilleux où
plus rien
je voyais aussi
c'était la quatrième et dernière visite
de la saison parce que le roi était à
cheval et les paysans devant effet amené
à ramasser le gibier en fait qui été
attrapé par le roi
notre magazine touche à sa fin mais
avant de nous quitter notez ces quelques
rendez vous le dimanche contre novembre
l'association des naturalistes des
yvelines vous invite à une balade
mycologique dans la forêt domaniale de
saint germain rendez vous à 9 heures sur
le parking de la piscine municipale de
saint germain en laye le dimanche 7
décembre c'est la ligue de protection
des oiseaux de guyancourt qui vous
propose une balade dans le temps que les
sources de la bièvre pour aller à la
rencontre de différentes espèces
d'oiseaux et pour finir vous pourrez
aller à la rencontre des canards et des
oiseaux qui passent l'hiver sur le plan
d'eau de la base de loisirs de moisson
mousseau équilibre c'est terminé
rendez-vous le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro 10 il a pensé à faire un
geste pour l'environnement